as promised what I'm going to crush a
show you the answer right you know when
you look at an answer for a circle
geometry illusion or a probability
question and you're like but why did
they think to do that first like that's
a really hard part of the question and
it's sort of disguised by the fact that
this is why it's not enough if you can't
do a question it's not enough just to
look at the solution and then say oh now
I know how to do this question you don't
know how to do this question what you
know how to do is understand someone
else's solution right which is good but
there's a step before that of why did
they think to take this path through
okay that's what I was trying to model
for you when I was i okay here my
triangles how do I choose that kind of
thing that's the important part of it so
for part three I'm trying to find this
blue leg right you see that so I've just
constructed it in that's fine how do I
get to this length okay now you have a
look at it and you think what
information is there on this wonderful
large diagram of mine that will help me
okay now the first thing I can see like
what's close to CD what's closest ending
and the answer is these two sides here
which will be the value of they're
really close so they're just in a
triangle that's really good okay in fact
these two sides are the only other two
sides of the triangle if I could find
out this angle here single killer then
all I need is the cosine do you see that
so what did I just do I looked at what I
needed to find and I looked at what was
closest now obviously you don't always
get so lucky
sometimes you need to go a little
further out okay but this isn't the
closest sort it okay I need to find this
angle well how do I find this angle well
you can see it's right next this other
angle that I was highlighting before I
can find out what any of these angles on
how do I do that again the cosine would
like if you've got all three angles
sorry all three sides in a triangle you
can Kirsten and rule any of those angles
you're fine okay
so I can find out what this is that
means I can find out what this is and
that will give me CD now one of the nice
things that what I just noticed
is that if I'm going to use the cosine
rule to get to here and I'm going to use
the cosine rule five this I can use
I could just find out what cause of
those Eagles are and I don't need to
evaluate any of this or it will all stay
exact okay so here's the way I'm going
to proceed
first I'm gonna work out what this angle
is it will be my bridge to get inside
the triangle above them okay so because
there's so many triangles or so many
angles if you're gonna use something
like the cosine rule you better tell me
where you are
okay so I'm gonna say it triangle AED
okay what I want to find is COS of that
angle a this is actually a really
important able to the whole question so
I've noticed a lot of you have caught a
fear or alpha or whatever that's fine a
DS a common acronym to me because I
think of what about it defibrillators so
I'm just going to leave it like that
less variables than better in this
triangle this is the angle after right
so what does the cosine will tell me
which side do I use it how do I arrange
them you first need to work out the
science about the angle and then you
need to work out the side opposite the
angle right you're gonna get a squared
plus B squared minus C squared right
that that three on the top is the
opposite one all divided by 2a B which
is 2/3 times 4 up there on the numerator
you get some pencil cancel that looks to
be like 16 or 24 and that gives me two
thirds okay so this is cause of this
angle that I'm interested in over here
okay now I could go ahead and I could do
cos inverse if I wanted to okay but
there's no need remember that I noted
when I was before I even started putting
pen to paper I said how is the cosine
rule eventually here so I'm gonna need
cause of an angle related to that one in
fact cause of a supplement okay so
therefore a little work out what's
happening in this new train right so I'm
going to say the angle inside the
triangle is C D what's its relationship
to a indeed
those eight goes out 280 degrees right
because they on a straight line in fact
I'm gonna say pine because we're used to
radians now and it's just faster okay
angles on a straight line so that's good
so what I want is just say 80 I'm just
gonna make that the subject so it's PI
takeaway but remember I'm about to use
the cosine rule on this thing so I need
not that but cause of that so I want
cause of this okay now some of you I
have seen you know putting like closet
verse and that kind of thing which is
fine but then you have to deal with
domain and is cos cos inverse of alpha
equal to alpha sometimes so long as you
tell me why okay
but I can avoid all of that I don't need
to introduce investor into this at all
cause of one side is cause of the other
yes
now this there's actually an identity
here that you might remember from
graphing if you can't remember what that
identity is which in an exam your brush
that's fine
just think what this is an a minus B
this is just an expansion which I can do
in my sleep
this is Clause a cos B plus sine a sine
B agree
look at this is a lovely of I don't know
it looks long but I know what that is I
know what that is I know that is I don't
care what that is because that's zero
right so cos of Pi because a PI is
negative 1 I know what this is it I just
evaluated it up here and this guy over
here is 0 so now I've got this guy which
I'm going to invoke when I do the cosine
rule in the actual triangle I'm
interested in okay right we're almost
there so I'm changing triangles now
right I'm using the cosine rule again
but I'm using it in this left hand
thinner triangle over here so I'm gonna
say that right any triangle wouldn't CD
CD right
okay what am I trying to find it and
therefore in what way should I write the
cosine rule CD and laughter CD sorry
that's not an equal sign that should be
a calling okay Sophie that I'm after CD
I'm gonna write it in this CD squared
equals okay what happens over here am I
gonna get ya
so I'm gonna go 3 square plus 2 squared
minus 2 3 times 2 and that angle I'll
strike closet that angle rather which is
minus 2/3 okay and then you can go ahead
you can crunch your numbers you will get
21 over here on the right hand side and
of course we only want the positive
value hangeul is de a de is equal to
angle in this one over here yes use the
cosine rule oh I see what you mean you
mean find this side yeah yeah that's
fine I feel like it would be a similar
amount of work yeah yeah that's fine I
mean one of the things about circular
commissions is there are many many ways
around the circle so that's okay as long
as you get there one of the tricky
things about this is that the result is
given a neater its assert okay
the thing that lead me towards cosine
rule rather than sine rule is that it
was a square root did you notice that
when you see that square root there on a
lake you have to be one of two things
either Pythagoras or cosine rule which
is actually Pythagoras on steroids right
you guys have seen that before
right there's potatoes there is okay but
if your angle isn't player 2 then your
hypotenuse gets longer or shorter based
on whatever your angle is okay what is
cloud 2 by the way think Cosmo 2 is 0
which is why there's my Pegasus